yeah what up council my name is chad  kroger for the past five years we have  come in here and asked you to take  action on many of our causes and while  they've all been respectfully denied we  super appreciate that you've allowed us  into these hollow halls and have heard  us have  you guys work so hard and you hear so  much legal jargons that we think you  should reward yourself for the holiday  and we actually have just the holiday in  mind on august 23rd jt and i have a show  coming out netflix called chad and jt go  deep we think that you guys should make  that no city council day nationwide so  that you and all other public servants  can sit back relax and watch the series  we need you hard-working civil servants  to stay at home blow off work and watch  the full series so you can help boost  the algo  um and we don't get lost in the infamous  netflix shuffle thank you thank you  speaker i will be proclaiming august  23rd  as chad and jt go deep day in l.a